yeah and I would say that it can I mean
that you know that that's why I don't
think you know I've never taken the view
that the only people who can provide
values of people of faith it is simply
that faith is one very common clear and
and actually I think hello there are
historical examples of faith leading to
very bad actions there are also many
historical historical evidence of
fatally new good action so but but but I
don't I don't take the view that that
you only religious people can give these
can get these values or give them in an
absolute sense incidentally you know
that there are I mean I mentioned the
people of faith who stood out against
the Nazis there are people of faith who
didn't stand out against the Nazis and
likewise there are people in no faith
who did so it's it's I don't actually
think one of the things that is is
necessary to have happen now is for the
secular and the faith communities to
start having a dialogue a little more
with each other because you know i think
i think the the religious people finally
you know that well the secular people i
think i'm finally getting over there
their notion that there's there's a
battle on and they're going to win and
the religious people i think should come
to terms with the fact that actually
there is a part of the secular that
brings something also very important to
our democracy and I say that as someone
of faith you know I wouldn't I wouldn't
I would not not want to live in a
theocracy